Robert Fowler's testimony is turning out
to be an absolute disaster for the
Democrats and the media they all told us
he was supposed to be the guy who was
going to take down the president and be
the savior of the Republic but after his
lackluster performance Democrats in the
media are now throwing Muller under the
bus
including filmmaker Michael Moore who
furiously tweeted a frail old man unable
to remember things
stumbling refusing to answer basic
questions I said it in 2017 and Muller
confirmed that today all you pundits and
moderates and lame Dems who told the
public to put their faith in the
esteemed Robert Muller just shut the
bleep up from now on
then there's a liberal media is eating
their own words after telling America
that Muller's testimony would be a
game-changer Democrats who were counting
on Muller to move the ball forward
didn't get exactly what they wanted
today they fumbled the entire
accountability a mission on optics this
was a disaster
there was a shaky performance I think
that's fair to say he looked like
somebody who would slow to step or two
maybe wasn't even control all those
angry Democrats it is shocking in the
age of Trump to look at the Democratic
Party and how inept they seem to be time
and time again meanwhile President Trump
and Republicans are in full-on victory
mode and rightfully so the Democrats had
nothing and now they have less than
nothing Bob Muller was trying to defend
the indefensible that report was
incoherent as written and it was worse
as played out on live TV a train wreck
an unmitigated disaster expectations
always outpaced the reality with
congressional hearings but the disparity
yesterday was pretty stark it's time for
the curtain to close on the Russia hoax
the conspiracy theory is dead all right
Martha
one of the main reasons and there's many
reasons why yesterday didn't go well but
one of the main reasons is he was never
going to live up to expectations because
the media had built Muller up to be a
god and he was in
teachable and and just a statesman and
tenacious and thorough and we didn't see
that and and everyone was disappointed
yeah I mean I don't think that this is a
question it's not a question of which
side you're on is a question of whether
or not this moment was politically
successful or whether it was politically
a failure and I think that you know and
that's why there's such broad spread
agreement that it was a political
failure I think that Jerry Nadler looks
terrible in this situation because he's
the one who put his party really on the
line and banked on this in such a big
way and think back to the moment when
Bill Barr a week or so ago said you know
if Muller decides not to go the DOJ will
back him on that right they delayed it
for a week then bill Barr sends out that
little message which I think was just
the the door opening saying you can take
a pass you don't have to do this because
there was knowledge behind the scenes I
think I'm a part of a lot of people a
that you know perhaps mr. Muller you
know wouldn't be able to present the
material in the way that would that
would really would would be a homerun
for them at this point you know and be
that the material itself was was lacking
right it wasn't just the optics it was
the substance of it because he'd never
been cross-examined Gregg no no one had
been cross-examined and he kind of
wilted under cross-examination
yeah they expected tirana MO when they
got Jared all you know the Trump
presidency has been nothing but a
succession of terrible Christmas
mornings for the media every week the
night before it happens once a week the
night before they're expecting that pony
but under the Christmas tree and they
get a bag of hair a bag of smelly hair
they expected molar to bring that bring
that case to life and he euthanized it
and it was it was and I again it was not
his fault they knew they were bringing
somebody out of retirement was like
asking a flying Wallenda at 95 to walk
between two buildings and he's been out
of practice why does this keep happening
it's the disconnect created by the
Democrats emotional bias the reality is
always going to be different than the
movie that they're watching so every day
for them is supposed to be Apocalypse
Now and it always ends up being happy
feet and I think what you're seeing here
is a hit they're irrational his stat
hysteria about this one thing led to the
big just a soul crushing defeat and I
almost but not really feel bad for them
no yesterday you said you felt bad for
my I texted you that and you were to
post this human being if you do feel a
little bit sorry they would have danced
amazing career and who obviously was put
in a situation that he should never been
put in and I just want to say one quick
thing no Brian kill me got lambasted for
coming out several weeks ago and saying
I wonder how familiar robert muller
really is with the details of the report
you know just just raked over the coals
well he looks pretty smart yesterday
wait a minute kill me but kill means
point we found that in the New York
Times reported this today Kenny Aaron's
elbe Lee who was the guy who was next to
him he aide he was effectively running
this investigation they said he was the
chief of staff running all the meetings
I guess who he was he was the guy that
represented the guy that set up
Clinton's secret email server and helped
him destroy blackberries with a hammer
so now we know that Clinton set up Trump
and then she investigated him oh that's
exciting
yeah material watching for Democrats is
why do they do a little bit more
investigation because they're they're
considering themselves an investigatory
body so why don't you figure out who has
the best answers and who has the best
defense of the Moller report and who can
frame it in such a way that it will do
the most political damage
it's obviously [ __ ] there are a lot of
political people on the team so if it's
Andrew Weissman like now you can't try
them out before the the joint committees
you just you absolutely cannot do that
and and the president was right about
taking too many bites at the Apple
because these are not horses in Central
Park these are supposed to be serious
legislators and they really whipped on
this one and we are so used to both
parties
spinning like tops when they get bad
news and it's one of the few times where
you will see
census on all sides and people saying
yeah wow this was really horrible one of
the theories one of the theories jessica
is that you know Muller is lawyer he
knew he was under oath and he's very
precise and he has a lot of integrity
and he wanted to just make sure he heard
all of the answers very clearly that's
why he asked everybody to repeat them so
specifically I don't think mocking I'm
not I'm just repeating a theory that's
been out there there's a lot of
disgusting theorizing that's going on in
commenting on his health and what status
he's in and I feel like in this
conversation so far we actually have
only really been talking about the
optics there were a number of pieces of
substance that came out of this hearing
that make a tremendous amount of
difference for instance President Trump
was not exonerated or exculpated because
you can't be you start with the
presumption of innocence yeah you know
there's no port that can do okay sure
moving on to the next one you're over
one Jessica Val Demmings in her
questioning uncovered in both hearings
that President Trump and other members
of his team had falsified their
testimony when they met with members of
the FBI and the select why are you look
at me perplexed I didn't hear that
I'll see guidelines right and what that
prohibited him from doing from the
get-go that's the referral not what Ted
Liu said that's not the reason that he
didn't indentity also verified that he
clarified to say that because of OLC
guidelines they were not trying to make
a determination in this not that he
couldn't be indicted only they could
determination it wasn't because the OLC
guidelines the OLC guidelines say that
you can't indict a sitting president but
that's actually they didn't even that
into it is my way doesn't mean he didn't
commit john determination of guilt is
essentially innocent right goes back to
your first point which you were wrong on
you can't decide this you go court
meteor shot
I'm sorry I doubted you are you saying
that things went well
no what I'm what I am saying is first of
all I do think the Intel committee
meeting hearing went well it went better
Adam Schiff knew exactly what he was
doing those questions were looking for
one-word answers he seemed clear on
where Bob Muller was and what he needed
to accomplish there are sound bytes for
Democrats coming out of this that will
be in every 20/20 ad talking about
working with Russians
Paul Manafort and they've they're gonna
remind any question perhaps but yeah I
don't think they're going we got to go
but if Democrats are gonna run campaign
ads on the Muller testimony sorry not
gonna happen